i'm gonna pull up this uh we got this
story oh yeah this is great story i love
that we that our guys wrote this for
teamcast.com that's a great picture
liberal utopia san francisco woman seen
holding ak-47 from passenger window of
speeding car it's amazing the uh there
there's the photo it's a lady hanging
out the window i guess she got arrested
um my understanding is it's not an ak-47
someone mentioned it's uh uh was it an
akm 74 something like that i don't know
for sure
but
she uh has terrible trigger terrible
trigger discipline she's ready man yeah
so but this brings up an interesting
issue i was thinking about uh you know
universal guns and stuff like that
if you're driving your car erratically
like i think the cop can pull you over
and say get out of the car like you're
driving a radical like if you're driving
drunk if you were brandishing a weapon
out of the side of a vehicle like i
don't think it's a violation of your
second amendment if a cop's like
i'm taking that away from you more
importantly with their finger on the
trigger yeah yeah should you bust people
just for that do you think if someone's
walking around carrying and then they
have their bad finger discipline like
she's holding the gun it looks like
i don't i don't i don't think she was
intending on shooting anybody i'm not
sure but she's holding it like low ready
basically with her finger on the trigger
yeah i think she should have that taken
away and you know she's the passenger
yeah yeah she is hanging out of the
window but this is the san francisco
dude
things are going well over there so i
was i was really curious though um and i
don't know if we read this in the
article but was this part of like a gang
war or something no i think she was just
driving
it was a speed event with a gun yeah it
was funny because a lot of comments were
like man she's so dumb but that photo is
awesome that's a pretty killer photo wow
wow it's not awesome dude i i look at
this i got i got to be honest this lady
out of a car holding that gun and i'm
not somebody who's got extensive
training i'm like
it's embarrassing
you know what i mean like if i took a
photo so we we did a photo shoot for uh
when we we had forest here for recoilmag
and i'm like very careful make sure
you're telling me how to stand and like
how to hold it because the last thing i
want is to have a photo of me holding it
wrong yeah like
she's going to be all over the internet
and i don't know if she cares though
she's not like it seems like since the
movies movies have been invented that
people have become desensitized to like
the horrors of of danger in a lot of
ways and and like because 150 years ago
if that had come out that that someone
was driving around like a psycho
screaming with their finger on the
trigger of a weapon that would be a huge
deal for that city they'd they'd have to
do something about that person but now
it's like it's a hero it's an action
hero like this or the dylan
where the john dillinger days
i almost didn't say that because there
were like what are they bonnie and clyde
and like they're old like villains that
were kind of looked at like heroes like
in the old days yeah anti-heroes or
i don't know it's kind of weird isn't it
yeah like john dillinger you know people
look back on him with some kind of
reverence it's like a mad distrust for
the state and like a love of local
authority yeah well now san francisco is
just devolving i mean could this be you
know it's really funny is we're sitting
here laughing like haha she's so dumb in
san francisco what's so dumb could this
be like the beginning of the wild west
days of america like where it's like the
dystopian era is beginning the the
eviction moratorium is totally illegal
biden's just basically blatantly
disregarding all law and precedence in
this country in rather extreme ways to
be fair obama and trump did kill
american citizens i think
obama's was a bit more egregious trump's
was a bit reckless
we've had bad orders from presidents for
a long time but now it's like
here at home you know what i mean like
when obama killed well i've got this
this mic arm
when when obama killed those americans
with a drone strike you know nobody knew
what happened and they didn't care yeah
and trump had ordered a commando raid
which ended up we believe killing a
little girl so actually i should say
that the the trump thing is not
confirmed though we believe it was the
case um people don't see that stuff now
you've got joe biden being like i'm
going to the supreme court to see if i
can do this thing and the supreme
court's like you can't do this thing and
then he's like congress can you do this
thing and they're like we can't do this
thing and he goes i'll do it anyway the
craziest thing is that joe biden
threatened to arrest people for evicting
somebody a year in jail
under what authority could he none
literally none literally the supreme
court's like you can't do it he goes
okay i'll do it anyway the supreme court
can't do anything to stop it so when you
see that and you see poop all over the
streets
i'll tell you this man this woman riding
around with their gun
what did you think was gonna happen when
people know they can break the law with
impunity in san francisco they walk that
guy walks into walgreens right no i'm
sorry he rides his bike into walgreens
and then he has a garbage bag and he
fills it up with stuff and then he rides
out and the security guard doesn't do
anything and chester bowden actually
defended the guy what she's he or what
he's just about he's the d.a he said
it was something like
oh he was desperate you know then and he
told this story a year ago about how we
have to make sure that we don't
we don't uh make unintended consequences
happen by arresting these dealers and
they told a story about how one dealer
was uh was trafficked here and had to
sell drugs to pay off the dealers who
were holding his dad hostage yes and i'm
like so you're saying this guy comes
here and he's selling drugs on our
streets and we have to tolerate it
because his dad's in danger
like
that makes literally no sense i'm sorry
like i don't want anything bad to happen
to his dad but how is it that we're
gonna let him deal drugs pay off the
kidnappers and rescue his dad what are
you talking about yeah it's bad to stop
that's san francisco this is what you
get when you get district attorneys much
like cory bush
who are like these progressive democrats
who are just like tear it all down yeah
i'm thinking about like ancient history
and basically the totalitarian of human
history if if someone were to go onto
like a farmer's land and take three of
their goats and then get caught and the
farmer's like why'd you take my goats
and they're like i had to feed my
starving family
they would hang that guy
[Laughter]
probably not even a trial they'd just
take him and like put him to death
basically for thievery
uh and we've gone now we're in such an
abundant society that it's like
thievery isn't isn't such a big deal
maybe it seems like well i feel like
we're able to see a lot more of like the
the extra downsides of theft and robbery
because i was learning the other day
they are two totally different things um
we can now see what robbery does to for
example businesses that work in a
neighborhood and we can see everything
it does to the it like disheartens the
people that live there and it makes them
want to leave like this lady riding
around like it's freaking grand theft
auto that's insanity i feel like all we
need is a drought for san francisco to
look like literal madness it's in a
drought what do you mean well there you
go this is mad max it's starting in
california california's in a drought
right oh my god drought is so bad that
they're stopping people from pulling
water at the delta gosh bro i gotta be
honest i'm looking at what's going on
with the with the eviction moratorium
the debt ceiling crisis those are very
very big unemployment just being cranked
up until september now you're seeing
stuff like this you're seeing more of
the defund the police stuff and i'm like
it is mad max like it is it is a
controlled collapse almost it feels like
imagi i i want you to picture this in
your heads everybody there's a giant
skyscraper
and there is a giant
voltron-like japanese robot punching
buildings
and the building is gets knocked over
and joe biden who's 70 feet tall grabs
it he's got hairy legs and he's got hair
very hair very hairy legs and he's
holding up the building as it's
collapsing and he's going come on
but it's too heavy so it's slowly
it's going down and then on no no no
this is not the end the the the end of
the beginning it's not a good movie it's
the end of the second second you know
you know in like sequels that are part
of trilogies it's always a cliffhanger
yeah that's it the cliffhanger is joe
biden can't lift the building back up
and he's like come on and it goes down
and then the sequel is it just crushes
him
it feels like the system is falling over
and they're trying to hold it doesn't
just feel like it's him yeah
yeah yeah when you get san francisco
with like people hanging out windows
like speeding and ladies holding a gun
i'm like
well let's not be frogs what do you
think was gonna happen what's the
difference between thievery and robbery
uh i guess the thievery doesn't require
any kind of holding somebody out to just
sneak in and take stuff whereas robbery
requires somebody to like cause threaten
some kind of physical oh physical harm
threat robbery would give me your stuff
and that's still somebody hugs you yeah
san francisco robberies still legal but
they're allowing petty thievery yeah
well um
everything under 950 the police
basically don't respond to because
they're misdemeanors or something like
that and so people can walk what about
what about 200 000 private security
forces do you think they'll respond if
something worth nine hundred fifty
dollars gets bro let me tell you let me
let me tell you about private security
private security will punch a punch a
cop in the face if their client wants
them to or needs them to no no joke they
have lawyers
right we've had people comment in super
chat talking about this but it's true
private security they do not care if
they have a client it depends it depends
well they don't have to play politics
either if you're hiring a 15 an hour
private security guard for an event he's
going to be like i don't care he
probably doesn't have
like for cory bush
she's 70 000 on private security and
she's a politician these are the kind of
people they're going to tell the cop to
screw off and the cops going to try and
walk through and they're going to block
them and be like we're not going to
you're not getting past us it's not
going to happen
now for millionaires and billionaires
those are the kind of guys who are like
literally would punch a cop in the face
security guards will do whatever they
want and they'll like fly the guy out of
the country
yeah they'll get him on a yacht and
they'll take him out him and his family
get him to get him 12 miles out to sea
or whatever take you to abu dhabi yep
set you up in a really nice hotel
nice suite
now don't do that we should be fun
you know until a police officer does
that for me to fund them
defund all the cops because they don't
provide us with that because they won't
take them out to international waters
after that
what if we get like uh a police and it
was like subscription service so you get
like police police plus and police goals
that's where it is that's what we're
headed to i mean if everything becomes
private security what other option do we
have people are just going to start iron
private security and local communities
they'll band together and go well the
police have been defunded and we need
some way to protect ourselves the
millionaires and billionaires have
private security so why don't we pull
together as a neighborhood and hire our
own private security force and then they
do and then we end up in kappa stand
which is crazy to me that the left have
become the proponents of that
a problem imagining like check it out
like you you someone breaks in your
house and like they run off you call the
police and like you're a regular working
class person and the cop shows up and
he's like i see you're using our uh our
our our uh basic package uh for police
service so uh the person's not you get
five bullets
as the the perpetrator is no longer here
i think you're safe and we have
fulfilled our requirements under the
basic plan have a nice day good sir feel
free to contact us if you'd ever like to
upgrade then you get someone who's got
like platinum platinum plus and the cop
shows up and they show up with a fruit
basket shoot their dog
they don't shoot your dog if you only
get the baby
they like put him down ethically with
like a nice injection but either way
your dog is going to die
well you did call us it is part of the
basket
if you don't want your dog you can see
like a basic package where they'll
they'll they'll apprehend the guy and
then let him go but then there's like
the gold package where they operate and
they'll actually take him to the
courthouse and do the paperwork for you
for the for the platinum platinum plus
if you're like a millionaire and you
spend like 20 grand a month on the
police bring the new crew they bring the
guy to your house they bring them into
the basement where there's chains over a
pipe
and they're like here you go sir is part
of the platinum platinum plus uh pro
dna for you
yeah you've got a piece of his hair
he's now going to live in your basement
i i heard that private security agents
cost it's the insurance uh to hire those
guys because like each person's like a
million dollars in insurance to cover so
you can't the normal person just cannot
afford that that's what i'm saying you
pull together isn't it and if people
started to come together because like
technically if you
get a legal weapon you are your own
private security force but as soon as
you start to to build a force i think
that you become then liable for
insurance
you know what you know what i really do
think though i think if we did abolish
the police it would basically be the end
of the us
because it's like you were saying what
would happen is people would either form
local militias or
local security companies would come in
now imagine this you live and let's call
it like let's call it uh hillside which
i'm sorry somebody watching lives in
hillside let's say there's a hillside
neighborhood and the police are all
disbanded and fall apart and so they say
we definitely need a security force you
know police for our local community so
they create one and they all put they
all pitch in money and now they have
their local hillside police well next
next to hillside is valley side and they
do the same thing and then one day a kid
from hillside gets into a fight with the
kid and valley side punches them the kid
goes on hits his head on the curb and
dies
the hillside kid runs away after the kid
dies and then the valley side police are
like we're going to go get him because
he you know he came in here then the
hillside police are like you can't come
in here and then you have feuding
neighborhoods as if they are like micro
nations if you get rid of the police i'm
not uh i i'm not gonna agree with the
end caps on this one that's why i say
when i talk about abolish the police
it's not for the same reason as a lot of
and caps and libertarians though they
have been calling me based for saying it
no i think what would really happen is
you'd have a conflict from regional
departments and then what one police
department's like we got to go to
here's a better example kid from
hillside goes to valley side and steals
a five thousand dollar you know uh item
and flees with it and then the hillside
cops are like you're not coming in our
neighborhood we don't know we don't care
and we're not investigating that for
whatever reason and the valley side cops
are like we're getting our property back
for our patrons and then what then they
go in there and they shoot everyone's
dog gang war yeah
they go in there everyone wakes up all
the dogs are dead the dogs are dead they
like sneak they come in their house
mission impossible from the ceiling like
just to take the dog out
that's assuming too that these
neighborhoods have the same laws because
then you'd start to get even more
granular local level law like it's okay
to steal up to two thousand dollars in
hillside but in valley side it's a it's
a crime yeah it's okay
look at san francisco when they said
they're not they're not gonna prosecute
these crimes people from all over the
area are going there to steal yeah
they're like hey freebie it's what
happened in ferguson the people who were
rioting in ferguson did not live there
they were smashing windows and stealing
stuff and it's got to be bleeding over
from san francisco into the surrounding
neighborhoods and cities
barbara boxer oh yeah democrat senator
from california got mugged by a child
okay a kid we'll call say kid because a
young teenager like an eighteen
seventeen year old no no no like fifteen
is it fourteen or fifty like six foot
180 pounds i don't know about that but
apparently he like pushed her grabbed
her phone she i think she i don't know
if she fell over but then he jumped in a
car and she was like why would you do
that to a grandma and i'm just like
you know there are bad people you need
to be protected from let me tell you
this it's crazy you ever see have you
seen that that purge episode of rick and
morty yes
the rich people think they're safe in
the purge they will make a world they
will truly regret yeah i remember that
yeah the the i
what i mean is these elite political
class individuals these democrats for
the most part i want to defund and get
rid of all these cops
i am of the firm belief that when they
do that they will absolutely regret it
well 100 when people say things like why
would somebody do something like this
okay there are so many reasons but did
you really think they wouldn't did you
not understand that there were people
out there that do those kinds of things
and like will hurt people and she
defunded the police for him though so
that he didn't get
he should have known he didn't get
profiled well but hold on was there like
a social worker nearby when this
happened to ask him about his feelings
before he mugged her yeah because then
it probably wouldn't happen so so scott
adams has this theory that democrats
really don't understand human motivation
and i'm inclined to agree because
democrats seemed inclined to believe
that people aren't going to do bad
things to other people
and if anything bad happens to for
example a minority or person in that
community it's because someone else is
doing a terrible thing so it's like
either you believe that everyone's
basically good or you think that
everyone's basically bad except
minorities i think i generally agree but
my thing with scott adams is i just
don't take political advice from
cartoonists that's fair i appreciate
that
right no no but he's making fun of
himself yeah yeah
yes but uh but yeah i am a cartoonist
but no i think that's true they don't
understand human motivation and if you
go to many of the thinkers that were
held up by the left or influenced the
left historically like rousseau who
think that humans are fundamentally good
um
you get into this place where the only
way someone could possibly do something
bad is if they were engineered by
society to commit the wrongdoing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you